[Music]
let's watch this lady call everyone a
bum I'm famous you [__] bum
the thing is man
they've prepared people for this what do
you mean there's been years of people
getting documented and exposed so now
people when they get filmed they kind of
have like jokes in mind they're like
[__] prepared
that's a good point actually
so filming something it did feel like
this was almost
like too smooth yeah yeah you guys did
nothing wrong
film me I'm Instagram famous
like What scenario is this I'll tell you
it's no but is she getting off she's
getting off before the flight takes off
yeah they're kicking her off
but they're not like they're not
escorting her out or anything they
usually give those people a chance
a lot of times we see it though they're
like nah I'm staying
I'm staying but she's like no [__] this
I'm out yeah they're like we need you to
leave and she's like [__] Y'all then
why is she getting kicked off who knows
man
loud perfume or something
maybe she's mean to someone
won't move I mean I think the line at
the end was kind of sick
oh you [__] bum yeah that I mean I'm
Instagram famous because that's like not
even a thing anymore no it really isn't
actually you know it's kind of like a
vintage thing to say
yeah that's a relic yeah exactly yeah
that's something that's something you
would have heard in 2012. it's a kind of
a throwback yeah I'm Instagram famous
[__] it's almost like it's almost
like ironic yeah I think she's doing
irony in this in our post-ironic society
yes oh she got her page got taken down
oh man she got a lot of hate I want to
see this Burger King video all right
Fair
play once for me it's racist man I can
say that right now
oh yells the n-word okay never mind wait
what was the top right one let me check
your hand yeah that one I want to see
that one
I'm gonna shake your hands
I want to shake his hand
won't be off the [__] plate I want to
shake his hand that's all I wanted you I
only want to do you
you wanted to shake that hand man you
know it's grimy on a plane
barefooted seat one just digging the
toes in the wall dude
I was
I don't I'm I'm ashamed to admit this
that was you
I took my socks off
first flight
I don't know why
I can't really explain it man that's
that is
man let me tell you man so we smash his
feet with a hammer
oh no bro no dude dude that is awesome
imagine like smelling like what the [__]
is you know there's some cream it smells
like me you know some creeps a foot came
through on the window oh yeah they're
like
someone's being a dick yeah oh my God
these people are never gonna [__]
complain yeah you know and then they
feel like a little ginger kiss on their
they're so like they're what the best
way to get the feet back exactly or just
yep
oh man
that's the next step almost like more
pictures of them you know
bro dogs out on the flight between two
seats
you're about to get kicked off that's
the new flex yeah do you know why wikivi
rating
do you know my Wiki fee rating you piece
of [__] you're lucky I put these up next
to you you [__] have you ever
gone dogs out on a flight [__] no bro
hell no that's disrespectful dude
keep your [__] why I did it man in
the shoes yeah I know I'm ashamed I the
next day I was like why the [__] did I
do that I don't care how beautiful your
feet are keep just not on flights yeah
no I I fully agree with you
I don't know what it is man it just
grosses me out yes planes are not
sanitary places no they're not one of my
friends his mom was a flight attendant
for his whole life
and he told me something what so you
never saw her oh I think you saw her
he told me something that has stuck with
me now he told me at like three four
months ago he said
my mom says never wash your hands on a
plane
that makes sense never
touch the water that comes out of the
Taps always use hand sanitizer if they
have it yeah and that is just [__]
stuck in my brain why what's the reason
I don't know it's just dirty water hmm
like I think it I think basically what
they do is they take the water from the
toilet just yep it's a one-way tube yeah
that goes right up to the top sense dude
that makes sense ew ew you also that's
why sometimes poop comes out of the
you're like oh
I've always wondered why literal turds
come out of the is the water supposed to
be like toothpaste
the water's a little sludgy you know
what I also don't like about the
airplane sinks is like dude it's like
washing your hands in a small cereal
bowl yeah yeah like you're gonna get net
I know this yeah yeah that's so true
also on a airplane bathroom
you know you got to use it in the first
30 minutes of the flight you gotta be
the one of the first 10 in there going
in the airplane bathroom halfway through
oh yeah dude dudes are pissed all over
the mirrors yeah door handles it's so
funny it's like clockwork it's like it's
like 20 minutes after everyone gets
their drink yep there's a line yeah I
had to go into the restroom after
somebody's mother blew it up I knew she
blew it up she she popped out she took a
long time and then she popped out her
face was like like
she did not think someone was gonna be
there she tried to time it
and I I just got away from the door
standing there smiling sorry yeah
and I said smell pretty bad in there
yeah you blow it up
[Music]
just make it in between me and her just
walking past her yo Unabomber what's
good
come in the mail did it oh
her daughter's like what do you say oh
it's just something between me and your
mom
nothing sexual you know
just some [__] we got into ah come on
give me Nooks
yeah bro was this a study released in
September found out the quality of
drinking water most Americans
washing one's hands little what
oh
yeah I mean airplanes are just they're
they're just it's [__] it's a city
bus in the air
it's not so you shouldn't be drinking
like you shouldn't be using the ice
that's what that means all right
It's usually the water is bottled water
yeah
actually no they bring around the cups
of water they do yeah but they usually
pour them out
of the bottle yeah when they come by the
drink cart they pour it up yeah but the
ice
the ice is the question yeah that's the
question where are they getting that ice
I'm eating that ice every time every
time
just that [__] toilet [__]
flight attendants oh no chocolate ice
they're just looking at it oh chocolate
ice that's pretty cool seat 16a
British Airways is so cool he's gonna
get E coli